how's it go raise me and we are back in
strata deep alright how's it going
beautiful sunset weights mr. Crabb I
mean dr. crab dr. crab is enjoying the
sunset I can see our Abel
he's never have a good one dr. crab and
I can appreciate a man who can
appreciate the sunset i potato plant I'm
gonna have to kill your potato plant
Yankee potato plants our main being a
doctor sure is hard all this murder is
children why he's not watching oh my god
I flew I threw so far like
[Music]
one Rock shard one for nation one stick
and we got ourself a knife of course of
course
now we're gonna go some scuba diving
baby and mr. crab you come in with me
it's dr. crab goddamnit
alright why are we going pitch don't
worry about it we go into our special
place whole new world where crabs aren't
supposed to be what sorry mr. crab
it's dr. crab oh my god
stab him in the ass stab the [ __ ] in
the ass
why won't you die like what the [ __ ] is
your problem where is that little
[ __ ] oh god there's so many aah
abort abort mission abort abort abortion
abortion you fill my breath
I'm the shake master how you brought
your arm you [ __ ] me why are they such
[ __ ] like sweedish sharks would not
do this
[Music]
king of the sea king of the sea king of
the sea I stab fishes like I'm in prison
[ __ ] all right let's seriously get some
fish I'm hungry
dr. crab hey I got one this game is so
beautiful and immersive I gotta say it's
it's gorgeous it's cool to play gotcha
[ __ ] oh oh I know that sound
hey buddy you came oh you [ __ ] [ __ ]
is that how you want to do it is that
how you want to do things you're flying
you're flying now you're flying
I can fly with my shark
ahahahahaha
I told you I [ __ ] told you yeah you
thought I wasn't gonna kill you cuz I
kill your mom they're just no empathy
from the Swedes
there's no empathy from the king of the
[ __ ] ocean you bitch-ass [ __ ] I'm
gonna nibble on my tits is that it you
wanna nibble on them you want a free
sample you want a free sample baby yeah
baby
Oh what is happening I'm flying I'm
flying with my shark
I put are you doing I was cool man I
love this house oh man if only I had a
friend over here that that would just be
perfect I mean if only I had like a
doctor or something to help me no don't
look at me like that boots its mr. crab
and Sharky Shannon the shark best
friends forever
dr. crab I do any pills mind movin a
[ __ ] inch he's a shark you know that
right let's have a barbecue Chanin hell
yeah pods we're gonna cook your mom wait
what we going barbecue like it's Shana's
mama Shanna's mama
there we go five all right [ __ ] it let's
place it here nice and cozy Shannon
there we go it's gonna be a delicious
meal oh and even spins they think this
is your mom's heart or Reliance maybe I
won't eat it though I don't they've been
tied in Wow
I gave a lot of food and it made me sick
great now I have it Bowl out thanks to
your mom thanks Shannon
what a great day what didn't you say
Shannon I miss my mama
ah come on she's right there what's your
problem Jesus Christ you wanted
dr. Crabbe is here to help you here you
go give it give Shannon a massage dr.
Crabbe
all right well [ __ ] it out okay I kind
of wanted to explore more but it's
getting late maybe I can go to sleep now
you want to go to sleep Shannon no we're
gonna sleep together that's so cute
we're cuddling Shannon that's my butt
you know
Oh shh shh shh
Oh Shannon you're awake man I slept like
a mouse
let's go for a morning swim your night
Shannon well we're flying again damn it
flush and fly we're best friends forever
Shannon is my senpai Shannon is not a
truck but she can fly who would've
thought that Shannon was so viable [ __ ]
Shannon
son of a [ __ ] oh god damn it
Shannon abandoned me rest in peace
Shannon our friendship will never be
forgotten
[Music]
let's go to the bottom oh god this is
scariest [ __ ] I think I'm supposed to be
here there we go I got you
I saved you Shannon I saved you from the
evil sharks it's you came back to me of
course I love you I would never let
anything happen to you would you have
you ever wanted to climb a tree Shannon
yes piss and let's do it it's beautiful
up here parents I've always wondered
what it feels like to be on top of the
world
this is where you belong Shannon you
were born a monkey let's scare some
fishes together hi fish hiya Doan Hey
look at me I'm a shark I'm not gonna eat
you though
[Music]
I can jump like a boss with Chenin like
Shannon is my friend
well thanks Shannon I just broke my ass
what if I launch myself on Shannon like
a really [ __ ] are alright here we go
oh my [ __ ] god Shannon you're the man
I'm a woman
goddammit of course of course
I think we're left in the episode there
if you enjoyed watching please hit that
like button if you want another episode
let me know and leave that like that
you're watching and as always stay
awesome bros
too much